I done every day waiting for you.
Darling. Don't
I love you?
Oh, she is.
I'll be brave. I'll let
standing in me
breath
for you, darling.
Don't love you.
I'll find you brought to me.
I, you
I have day
Waiting For you.
Don't you
love you for
I'll find you.
It is amazing how you can speak right
without saying
You Light up.
Don't
the smile
On all you face, Let
Know And you need me.
There's the truth in your eyes saying you'll never
Leave me.
The of your hand says, you catch me wherever
I fall
all
Long. I
can hear people talking.
When crowd,
What's Between your
Heart?
A smile On your face? Lets know that you
Leave me. There's a truth
In your eyes Saying
You'll never leave me.
Your head says, you can't Forever. I fall.
When you say
You'll,
you
Save
anything
by you,
the
you do.
First thing that I'm gonna do, spread my wings.
When
I get where I going,
There'll be Only
Happy. I'll
Share and struggles I have carried
All these years Now
where I'm going, there'll
happy's,
Sometimes late.
I you can watch her sleep.
She's lost in peaceful dreams.
So I turn out the lights and lay there
and the thought cross.
I never in morning
the way I,
my true
much means.
And that circumstance where there's no second chance,
She
Must.
I was young. So
Disassemble, we came
together broke.
You may be seated.
Well welcome and thank you guys for all coming today.
Um, we appreciate you joining us
in this celebration of life
and equally of legacy of my dad, Gary Henley.
So by, uh, on the behalf of Peggy, myself,
and our entire family, again, we wanna thank you
for making time to carve out today for him.
Before we get started, let me pray for us.
Father God, thank you.
Thank you for being a loving, merciful, and forgiving God.
Thank you for being mighty
and sovereign in both
of which we can find refuge and peace.
Father, thank you for today this gathering of people coming
to celebrate our beloved Gary.
Thank you for the outpouring of love to Peggy
and our entire family.
For those not only gathered here,
but from across the country.
And Father, today, we will honor Gary
and we'll celebrate his life in this holy place.
And we will be comforted by the fact
that you hold him in heaven.
Amen.
43 years ago at the ripe age of 18,
I was hired by Gary on my first full-time job.
Little did I know what I was getting into
because later he introduced me to a feisty redhead.
And from that very moment, we have been inseparable.
So today I'd like to share just a few things
that are on her heart.
ALSA love story.
I loved hearing the phrase that ALS is a love story.
It certainly was for Gary and I,
after his diagnosis,
the first thing Gary said was, it is what it is.
He faced this disease just like everything else in his life
with a positive attitude and an enormous amount of grace.
He was a humble, generous, loving person.
Never a bragger,
but always a person
who loved others in an unconditional way.
He was showered with FaceTime calls, cards,
and visits by many of you, which he truly treasured.
He was never angry. He said he was just sad.
He taught me what true grace was
and the people that knew him best were
better for knowing him.
And I'm a better person
for having walked this journey with him.
We truly brought out the best in each other.
I had many times throughout our life together that I said,
if it all ended tomorrow, how great is our life?
Our love story gave us time to reflect on our 35 plus years.
Together, we had the opportunity to embrace the beautiful,
blessed life We have lived the amazing places we were able
to travel to, and
so many wonderful friends we met along the way.
We talked about those treasured friends
and how much he's meant to them in friendship and career.
He found comfort in knowing how many friends
and family would be there to support me Through all of this.
Memories of us will always bring a smile to my face,
especially when I look out over t.
That was our happy place.
Our last Christmas was spent there with our family.
Gary and I sat back watching our kids adults together,
and I said, is this what we dreamed of
for the next generation?
When we sat in the wrought iron chairs on the porch
and looked out over Alberta Creek
and made the decision to buy that place for our family
and future families, family,
and many friends have shared that special place
and created some of the best memories.
My hope is to make Gary proud of me
and keep fulfilling our dreams.
I've asked that the poem, the dash be shared with you.
The dash is what Your life is birth to.
Passing The dash
by Linda Ellis.
I read of a man who stood to speak at a funeral of a friend.
He referred to the dates on the tombstone from the
beginning to the end.
He noticed that first came the date of birth
and spoke of the following date with tears.
But he said what mattered most of all was the dash
between those years for that dash
represents all the time they spent alive on earth.
And now only those who love them.
Know what that little line is worth for.
It matters not how much we own the cars,
the house, the cash.
What matters is how we live and love
and how we spend our dash.
So think about this long and hard.
Are there things you'd like to change for you never know
how much time is left that can still be rearranged
to be less quick to anger and show appreciation more.
And love the people in our lives like
we've never loved before.
If we treat each other with respect
and more often, wear a smile remembering
that this special dash might only last a little while.
So, so when your eulogy is being read
with your life's actions to rehash, would you be proud
of the things they say about you
and how you lived your dash?
You're about to hear from some of Gary's colleagues
and best friends, and they will certainly share what
made up Gary's dash.
I can it be
like when I,
I can only imagine what my eyes would see
when
I can only imagine
glory.
What will my heart feel?
Will I dance for your Jesus over and all?
Will you be still?
Will I stand in your presence to my knees?
Will I fall, will sing?
Will I be able to speak it home? I can only imagine?
I can only imagine.
I can only imagine when
that day comes
and I find my sin standing in the sun.
I can only imagine when all I would do
is forever, forever worship you.
I can only imagine.
I can only imagine
surrounded by your glory.
One, will my heart feel will I dance for you?
Jesus, over all of you, be still.
Will I stand in your presence to my knees?
Will I fall? Will I sing? Hallelujah?
Will I be able to speak at all? I can only imagine?
Yes, I can only imagine
surrounded by glory.
What will my heart be?
You will I dance for you, Jesus and all.
Will you be still? Will I stand in your presence?
My knees? Will I fall?
Will I, will I be able
to speak it home? I can
Only imagine?
I can only imagine.
I can only imagine
I can
when all I would
Do Is
Forever, forever worship
You.
I can imagine.
My name is Cliff Dowdy.
Um, I had a privilege to share 50 years of Gary's dash
and, uh, made life a true adventure.
Made life challenging.
It was about a year ago when Gary called,
and I could tell by the message he left on my phone
that something was wrong.
And we found out the, the battle that he was up against
Gary and I had many, uh, conversations
where he could still talk about the battle
that he was facing and that he would be up to it.
I'm thankful, very thankful that in
that roughly year time, we had an opportunity to meet,
be together a number of times.
We had a lot to share.
Uh, there's not enough time today to cover
what happens in 50 years with somebody, but he
and I discussed a lot of that.
We discussed the, uh,
we talked about life, we talked about death,
and we talked about life after death.
You know, those are conversations when you're younger,
you go, you know, at some point we're gonna deal with this.
But it's always tomorrow. You tomorrow got here.
I met Gary in 1973.
I was still going to school at ou.
We ended up working at an electronics company together.
Gary was doing sales.
I was doing engineering and technical work there.
I had become interested in video technology at the time.
Very few people even knew what video was.
Uh, it wasn't a well understood term or technology.
And, uh, I had made a proposal.
We were working for a kind of a medical company.
Anyway, I'd made a proposal to add cameras
to a local hospital intensive care unit
for patient monitoring.
And it was immediately turned down that it was a crazy idea.
Not long after that, Gary were, Gary
and I were out on a service call,
and I expressed to Gary my total disappointment of
what a ridiculous response.
Gary picks right up on it
and soon starts discussing, gee,
there's business opportunities there.
And we're off and running. Shortly afterwards,
Gary, uh, at the time I was going to school,
living in a mobile home.
Shortly afterwards, we met at my mobile home.
I had a little lab, electronics lab
with only a handshake.
We began what was called at that time,
electronic Systems Unlimited.
And I want to emphasize only a handshake.
Uh, that's how we got started.
It wasn't like a big business deal.
We quickly moved my equipment to Gary's garage.
He was living in a small three bedroom home
with a single car garage.
And, uh, I'll never forget, we worked outta the garage.
Gary's kitchen table was where a sales
and business took place.
So about that time, Eric came along.
More often than not, he was confined to the backyard.
We worked hard. We took on anything we could find.
We were poor boys. But
soon Gary figured it was time.
We really step into the video business.
Gary, being the consummate sell salesman
and businessman, it wasn't long.
He contacted a large Japanese video company.
A few days later, a Mercedes-Benz pulls up in front
of Gary's house, happens to be sales manager
for half the United States for this company.
Uh, and we commits to sit down at the table
with his gentleman, talk about the opportunities,
and with no office, no money,
no sales force other than Gary sitting at a kitchen table,
we convinced this salesman that we could sell,
design and install anything they had.
So shortly a thereafter, we changed the name of the company
to Electronic Systems Incorporated.
Gary, I, I used to say Gary could make sales
and come up with things to do so fast
that it would take at least five
engineers to stay up with him.
So for my survival, we put on some more help.
As time passed, we moved from the garage
to a small office building,
was not a high class office.
We shared a building with a bar and a liquor store.
True adventure. But we grew
and we expanded in about three years.
We outgrew that office.
We launched a plan to have our own building.
And of course, Gary knew somebody that was a builder
and could find us land.
And shortly thereafter, we had a building program underway.
At that time, Gary and I did a lot of hunting together
and, uh, duck hunting was a big deal.
It was like a religion for us.
And, uh, it, I think it was where we, uh, the stresses
of work kind of went
to the side when we actually went and had fun.
So of course, in this new office, it had to have
a facility, a shower,
and a place that we could go duck hunting early in the
morning, come back to the office
and clean up and go to work.
It looked like we were, you know,
real hardworking people, which we were.
The story quickly grew from there.
We ended up, as I remember,
about a 200 page product catalog.
Gary's out pounding to pave it. Gary's always making a deal.
Gary's always making a sale, but that wasn't enough.
Eventually, underneath the ESI,
we developed four more sub corporations
underneath that business.
Those were very busy days.
Anything from video broadcast to security, to systems
that went on offshore drilling platforms.
Gary had us hooked up.
We were busy somewhere in all that,
I did find time to meet the love of my wife
life and get married.
However, Gary
and I did spend a lot of hours at the office.
We had catches in our office
and they, that's where guests would sit by the day
during the day when they would come in.
It's also where we'd sleep at night when we were working
sometimes, however, I did find time to go home.
I now have two sons. I, Gary
and I made out for starting with nothing with hard work.
A hundred percent faith,
a hundred percent confidence in each other.
No binding contract, just a common goal.
Um, I used to always say, we would show up at the office,
put our keys in the door, open that door up,
and we both went to our, each our, each area of work.
But we weren't ever guessing what the other one was doing.
It was all based on faith and confidence and a common goal.
We survived a lot of hard times, a lot of good times.
Lemme tell you what, the hard times made those good times,
those mountaintop experiences, absolutely grand.
And we would celebrate.
Often we would go pheasant hungry.
I'm wearing a pheasant tie today.
It's a little tattered, been around a while,
but it's in remembrance of so many times that I spent
with Gary and Yik Remember taking him hunting
with us when he was big enough to carry a gun.
And often, you know, you spend all day hunting.
Some days you got good luck, sometimes you don't.
But I remember towards the end of the day,
after a long day of walking, we'd look at each other
and go, Hey, you got another mile in you.
Maybe, maybe we'll have better luck.
Same thing would happen at the office.
What we did when we weren't in the office
was often a reflection of
what happened at the office when we were working
so many times, particularly there was, uh,
some difficult times during the eighties.
We would look at each other
and go, you got another mile in you,
and we'd go after it again.
Even though for a normal sane person,
it seemed totally unreasonable.
Excuse me. In the Bible,
there's a verse, Ecclesiastes four, nine to 10.
You may be familiar with it,
but it goes, here's the verse two or better than one,
because they have a good return for their labor.
If either of them falls down, one can help the other up
pity on the one who falls down
and has no one to help them up.
That's how it was with Gary as a partner.
Whether it was the times he took me to the hospital,
which did happen a couple of times,
or the times I'd go by his house.
At one time, Gary had a very severe lower back issue,
and I would go by his home
and I'd help him get ready to come to work.
And so we carried each other,
whether it was at work or whether it was in personal life.
It's like, what are we gotta do? That's what we did. Okay.
There's a lot of stories.
There's no way I can put 50 years
of stories into short comments up here today.
Um, but there's some funny ones.
We were pheasant hunting in one time, in a
fold out tent trailer.
Those of you from Oklahoma knows how the know
how the wind can blow at times.
So we got caught in a pretty significant
windstorm while we're hunting.
Gary loved to cook. He's at the stove cooking.
I'm doing everything, trying
to hold this tent trailer together
to keep it from blowing over or blowing apart.
Another time we're out duck hunting one morning.
And, uh, it was a pretty dense wooded swamp fog sets in.
We begin to wonder if we'd ever find our way out.
But we did. And it was another time.
I, I was kind of a Corvette fanatic at one time.
So I just finished putting
one together, took it to the office.
Gary gets in it, we pull out on MacArthur and he nails it.
Uh, we're accelerating towards a red light.
He lets up on the gas. And lo and behold, gas pedals stuck.
But we managed to get it shut down just in time.
Most of those experiences like that outside
of work was a reflection of how we made it at work.
It was always so many times just in time, but it was
because we were together
and we were in sync in business.
Gary always brought so many cal challenges.
It required a lot of commitment, required a lot of growth.
Life was never boring with Gary
during those days and months and years.
Long, hard hours. We became more more than partners.
We were like brothers. We could communicate
even without talking.
Quote came to mind as I was thinking about this, that
somehow summarizes what the partnership was
between Gary and I.
This is a quote from Warren Buffett.
Partnership is not a legal contract
between two equal individuals.
There's an emotional alliance between two people
who are committed to each other's success.
I give thanks to Gary in those early years
that ended up charting his life course
in my own life course.
We were blessed with people who believed in us.
We had so many employees that stuck it out
to the good times and the bad times.
We were a family. Eventually, Gary
and I did take different paths, which allowed each one of us
to pursue our own dreams.
That was okay. We were still partners.
A few days before Gary passed,
I sent him a text and we were talking about this
long life, this dash of life that we had spent together
about all the things that happened, the ups and downs.
And his last response to me was,
and yes, we're still partners.
That's a pretty special statement to me.
Uh, it's not often you go through life
and spend that much time with somebody who's maybe not your
spouse, and you still have that type of a
close bond, a bond that even whether you're part
or together, there's still a bond that doesn't go away.
So Gary and I talked about as we led up to this,
we had talked about what were, that he knew he was facing
death and we agreed based on the common faith
That we would see each other again.
Thank you.
Good morning. My name is Charlie Federico.
I'm from Charlotte, North Carolina.
An interesting part
of starting this is thinking back on the relationship
that Guyer and I formed, which is now has been 40 years.
And what you've got is a kid who grew up in the streets
of the Bronx in New York City, somehow
became best friends with a kid
who grew up in the backwoods of Missouri.
And, uh, I discovered,
and I've said it to Gary many times, that God,
I've been a country boy my whole life.
I just was trapped in the north.
I didn't realize how much fun we could have, you know?
And we were partners not only in business,
but part what I call it partners in fun.
And I wanna share a couple of stories with you
and please feel free to laugh if they're funny,
but laugh anyway, if they're not, you know, In 1980,
I'm gonna overlap some of the things Cliff told you when
they were struggling back in the early eighties.
I met Gary in 1983
and at that point I was in the arthroscopy business.
One of the bigger players in that.
And Arthroscopes were a thing of the past.
It was video cameras attached to Arthroscopes.
That was the trend. And this is
so the people in the operating room could see what's going
on and the doctor could do comment and all that.
It lightened up the whole surgery instead
of watching somebody for two hours with a round tube looking
inside a knee, trying to figure out what's going on.
So all the major companies scrambled
to find a partner for a video.
And I met Gary, I believe it was an academy meeting,
I'm not sure, I don't remember.
But, uh, he had C Corp
and C Corp was a company
that was producing handheld cameras.
And I was looking for a partner.
I didn't want to be one in one of those situations
where I was at the whims of a vendor of some sort.
So I wanted to buy something.
And I mentioned that to Gary
and we had our first conversation about this guess where
on a golf course, except we weren't playing.
We just walked the golf path Mountain, talking about life,
talking about my vision for
what I think these this company could look like.
Gary was extremely interested in, in how his people would do
in a situation like that.
We spent a lot of time on that,
and I'm happy to say I think I've honored everything I told
him that we would do.
And, uh, his facility continued to grow
and the business moved to Oklahoma City.
And, uh, we started these
negotiations, I'll call 'em negotiations
because they were kind of, you know,
the agendas were a little different, but not really.
I mean, it was just try to make something happen rather
than the word negotiation.
And it got to the point where we
weren't making a lot of progress.
So I invited Gary to fly up to, uh, Boston,
and it was in the fall, and he showed up
and he had a pair of jeans, uh, a golf sha, a shirt
and a windbreaker on.
He gets in the car and,
and he thinks he's going to the office,
but I take him to the Merrimack River
where I had my bass boat and I said, we're going fishing.
He goes, okay, had to be 50 degrees.
The water was pretty cold.
And I drove about 12 miles at 50 miles an hour
up the Merrimack River.
And I get up there and I look at Gary
and he is purple, absolutely purple.
And I just smiled to my side.
I didn't say anything and I,
we started fishing this one little
hole that I liked on the river.
And, you know, it happened many times.
I caught a dozen and Gary caught one, alright?
And I looked at him and I said, you know,
this is all about the art of negotiation.
I said, one of the main principles is you take your opponent
to an unfamiliar place and you make them uncomfortable.
Have I succeeded? He could for this lovely crowd.
I can't tell you what he what I said,
but you can imagine what he said, you know, well soon
after, not necessarily because that,
but maybe he didn't want another fishing trip in
Massachusetts, I don't know.
But we were able to put it together
and uh, uh, we had a big celebration dinner
in Boston after the, the business closed one night.
And, uh, I think Peggy needs to tell you stories about that.
I mean, she fell in love with lobster
and good wine that night
and, uh, was overserved certainly, you know,
and, uh, there's a couple of stories that Peggy can,
can enhance with you.
So from there, in 1997, I was recruited
to a company called Orthofix as the CEO.
And it was a public company at the time,
and it was an experience of a public company.
It was not experienced. I had,
I had been a president since 33 years old,
but never a public company.
So I was intrigued by it and took the position.
And, uh, my wife, Joanne, who can't be with us today,
and dear friends of Gary
and Peggy also, uh, did not wanna move to Texas.
I I certainly can't explain why not.
I mean, but I, I had to go so that we got an apartment,
a two bedroom apartment in Richardson, Texas.
And, uh, I proceeded
to show up in October of 97, and
after three months, the, the alarms went off in my head.
I need Gary. Remember Gary
and I had worked together a long time
and I said, I got some inside problems.
I got some outside problems, I got all kinds of issues.
And Gary had been, how do I describe this?
Had taken adventure into the restaurant
business at this period.
And for some reason he was ready to do something else.
I, you know, those of you closer to it may know,
may know the reason I, it was Billy Belu, right?
Yeah. I thought Billy be blues was a lot of fun.
But, uh, he, uh, he looked favorably on the idea
of coming in to, uh, ortho fix
and being my, you know, being partners in artifacts.
Like we were at s and I told them to come down.
I have this two bedroom apartment, uh,
get used to it and all that stuff.
No, no fast relocation necessary, anything.
We can work this out and you can get comfortable.
And if you're comfortable and
you wanna move down, let's fine.
But I'm not gonna force you
to do anything you don't wanna do.
And that actually worked pretty well.
So here was born the first odd couple,
and whichever one of us got home last would open the door
and say, honey, I'm home.
Gary knew his way around the kitchen. I was a slob.
So the two of us did fine. Yeah.
And it was in the beginning that we went to Kmart
and we bought a one of those round plastic tables about
this big a round and two plastic chairs
for about $25 I remember.
And we bought an $80 bottle of scotch
and had, we had a little patio outside this apartment,
and we put those chairs in that table out there
with the bottle of scotch and we'd get home
at all crazy hours.
And we'd sit out there at night and crack that scotch open.
And I will tell you today,
I wouldn't have told you when I was running a public
company, there wasn't one major decision made about
what we were doing in that company that was not made on
that patio, right?
That was the routine. You
know, what'd you, what was your day like?
What'd you find out? Blah, blah, blah, you know?
And we proceeded to, to work very hard
and, uh, I can only give you the accomplishments
after 10 years
or so, whatever it was that the, we took,
when I took the company over,
the share price was $4 a share.
It had gone public at $10, it traded up to 20,
and they made an acquisition in the us which the integration
fell on its face and hence the $4 share price
and losing money, it took us till June
of 98, which is six months of Gary
and eight months of me to get that company profitable.
It wasn't pleasant, but we got it profitable.
It took us a little while longer to understand the metrics
and the buttons you have to push to make the performance
of the company look right.
Nothing illegal, but just the blending of all the businesses
and how it all comes together.
And once we got that, we started reporting quarterly results
And share price.
At the end of my,
my reign there was about $45.
So it actually worked out well.
But the bottom line on that is that the quarterly results
of sales and earnings,
we hit our targets 37 quarters in a row.
Okay? And I give a lot of that credit for that to Gary
because it was an operations business,
and that's where we were hurt,
and that's where we had to take the money at.
That's where we take the focus.
That's where we had to get our arms around it.
And he did a hell of a job, right?
And we both enjoyed the success.
Now we've had plenty of failures,
but that, you know, was a tough one, but it was a success.
Oops. Successful one. All right.
That's sort of enough of the, the business stories.
I think that, uh, the fun stories,
I'll start out with the meatball story.
All that apartment that we lived in,
Everybody at the company knew we were two
bachelors in that apartment.
We probably weren't eating right, you know,
which we weren't and so forth.
So all of a sudden, every morning on my desk is a Tupperware
with some sort of dinner item for us
that we could just heat up and, and, and have.
And we, I mean, we survived in that stuff.
I mean, as much as Gary liked to cook,
when you're getting there eight o'clock at night,
you don't want cooking dinner.
So we had our little scotch on the porch
and we went inside, all right, let's see what we got.
And opened this container up
and in it is three big
meatballs, and we're looking at them.
So I said to Gary, I said, well, who gets two?
And who gets one? And he's looking at me.
I said, I have an idea. There's a golf course over here
that's lit at night.
It's nine holes. I said,
let's go play nine holes for a meatball.
He's not here to defend himself.
I won't tell you who won, but, so one of us got two
and one of us had one.
And that was sort of the spirit that,
that we operated under.
I mean, it was just a, you know, you know,
we've been very fortunate.
We, we've been able to play golf, we've been able to fish,
we've been able to chase turkeys in some
of the most beautiful places in the world.
And we coined a phrase, it's not, it's not unique to us,
but we used it a lot, which is having fun is hard work.
Illustration of that is, one day when we were hunting
with this guy over here out in, in, uh, Kansas,
I looked at my iPhone at the end of the day
and I walked 19 miles
and I climbed 99 stories trying to chase a Turkey down.
And that was not unique. That was not a unique day.
That was a typical day on a, you know,
a hundred thousand acre farm.
And, uh, you know, so
there was a little work.
And the last story would be
at a board meeting at Orthofix.
The chairman lived in the Seychelles,
and we had a plant in the Seychelles.
So he decided we should have a meeting and the,
and we should all fly to the Seychelles
and have a board meeting on a place called Bird Island.
You remember Peggy? Yes.
All of you need to ask Peggy about her experiences on Bird
Island, but it was the kind of place
that was nothing to do except this resort.
And in the evening after the meeting,
everybody would get out
and walk the circumference of the island,
which was about a mile and chitchat and so forth.
Well, I'm not gonna have any of that. I had a fly rod.
So I went down to the beach
and I go out to where the waves are breaking
and I start fishing the fly rod.
And lo and behold,
I hook a massive fish called a Grand Traval.
And for those of you who don't fish, there's, there's
so much line on a flywheel.
And this fish took all the line
and all the backing I got right down to the end,
and I could do nothing but hold the spool and broke him off.
And I said, my God.
So that night I tell Gary this story,
I said, I got found this place.
I said, you know, let's get up before breakfast.
Let's go out there before all the nonsense starts,
and let's see if we can hooks as many
of these things with a fly rod.
He said, okay. So we go out, it's dark
and there's a, what they call a flat about the size
of this auditorium to the, where the breakers are.
And the water's only about two feet deep.
So we proceed to hike through this thing,
and we line up about 20 feet apart,
and we're casting flies out into the surf.
And at the exact same moment, Gary
and I see a tiger shark that had to be the size
of a car in the breakers just cruising in front of us.
And you swore that his eye
was looking right at the two of us.
I mean, and he, I mean he, we were at the end of this.
So it was simultaneously.
And I, I remember turning to Gary
and saying, I don't have to be fast.
I just have to be faster than you.
Well, I mean, like Cliff, of course, 40 years I could,
you know, we could spend the whole day.
And I'm happy to tell stories about Gary if you'd like me
to, but I think in the sense that we have other people
that need to speak on a serious note.
I, the last time I saw Gary, we hugged
as I was leaving, I thanked him
for sharing, well, what's called now the dash.
But I said to him, this period of my life
where our families were intertwined, our business
and our fund was all intertwined.
And I thanked him for that.
And I told him that a day would not go by
where I didn't think about him.
And it's certainly these days it has been.
And Gary, you had that little machine at the end,
you talked about it, cliff, and he wrote me a text
and I've got, I wanna read it to you.
I'll try to read it to you. Thank you for coming.
Great to see you.
You are my brother from another mother.
Yes. Rest in peace, my brother.
Thank you.
Good afternoon. These stories are so special
And, and it's bringing out the, the character
of our good buddy.
My name is Greg Nelson. I'm from Carlsbad, California.
Uh, I met Gary the summer of 1987
when he sold his camera company
that you learned about to Smith and Nephew.
Later on that summer, I sold my company to Smith and Nephew.
Earlier that year, Charlie was made president of Ionix,
a Smith and nephew company.
And the three Stooges were born
36 years have passed since that time.
And boy, they go quickly.
I've got many, many stories, but I'm not gonna go there.
I'm just gonna say that the best thing
that happened in those 36 years is
that our three wives fell in love with each other.
And that has allowed us to travel, especially
after we quit running companies and,
and doing all the things that we were doing,
raising families and so on.
Uh, but we, especially the last few years, traveling
to great resorts, playing lots of golf, drinking great wine,
and having the times of our life, uh,
we've even named it adult camp.
Gary is a stud, I don't wanna say was 'cause he is a stud
and he could do anything.
We've, you've heard some of the stories of his partners.
Um, and he's done many things for us.
Uh, years ago, uh, Peggy and Gary were leaving Memphis.
And I had a company in Dallas that was frankly in trouble.
And I fired the CEO and I called Gary
and I said, Gary, can you give me a hand?
I said, you can do this job standing on your head.
And he said, yeah, I, I'll give you a hand.
So he was ACEO of this company,
and it took him, it took him a little while.
It wasn't standing on his head.
It took him a while, but he got
that ship turned all the way around.
And, you know, he can do anything if you
just give him the opportunity.
But I remember him telling me,
you gotta peel back the onion.
You gotta look at it, peel back the onion
and you figure things out.
Gary loved his family, so proud of each one of you.
And he would do anything, anything for any one of you.
But he adored Peggy.
I I would see him when Peggy would walk into the room
and Gary would just smile.
She's here. He, Gary, also loved all your, many, many,
many girlfriends.
And I heard stories. I was never there.
But I heard stories of the visits to your homes,
to the lake house where Gary would cook, clean,
pour wine, always pouring wine.
Matter of fact, last time Barbie
and I were with Gary, um, a few months ago,
he on his little machine, he said,
anytime my my glass got half full of wine.
He said, you need more wine. You need more wine.
You need more wine. Yeah.
But, you know, I don't know if heaven has hunting
and fishing and golf,
but if, if there is that in heaven, Gary's gotta be one
of the best people there
because he was so competitive in everything he ever did.
And he was good at it. You know, many of us,
probably most people in this room believe that
God took Gary too soon,
but God doesn't make any mistakes.
And he's got a plan for each one of us.
And I know I'll see Gary again soon,
but I hope it's not tomorrow.
I, I love you, man.
Story of my life is following these three giants.
Um, these are three giants in the
industry and they're great men
and they commanded a lot of attention.
That's all over now. Um, I was grunt labor.
Um, I, I, I don't know why, but, um, I'm up here.
I love Gary so much. He hired me.
Uh, well, I knew him for a long time.
And we would meet at different meetings
and we'd always play golf.
And, uh, we'd drink wine
and we'd play more golf, drink more wine.
And, uh, we shared customers
and we immediately, Lee had a kinship.
And I loved him so much.
I was born in North Carolina, um,
and lived there for 10 years
before I moved to Florida where I live now.
And, um, my favorite thing to do there was to go over
to my granddaddy's house, uh, Percy Smith.
My father's dad had lots of cousins there.
But, uh, I wanted to go to Granddaddy's.
'cause when I got there, granddaddy stopped
everything he was doing.
He go, son, you need a, you, you don't have a
a slingshot, do you?
I'm gonna go make you the best slingshot.
We'd go out to the shop and he'd, we'd go find a tree here
or whatever he'd do, and he'd make me a slingshot.
And then we'd spend most of the days practicing with it.
But he stopped everything he did, and it was me.
And I come again. He goes, you ever had a rubber band gun?
Oh man, every kid's gotta have a rubber band gun.
We'd go out to his shop, he'd make me a rubber band gun.
We'd nail down a little, um, Uh,
clothes hanger on thing, you know, and we'd make a, and
and we had so much fun.
As I got a little older, he'd say, I'm hungry.
Let's go down to Piggly Wiggly.
And, uh, he'd buy me a banana split.
I, I thought I'd died and gone to heaven.
My dad wouldn't give me a snow cone.
Uh, it was, he'd buy me a banana split.
And, um, when I got a little older, when I hit 14, he said,
let's go to piggy with.
And I mean, he stopped everything.
And his full attention was on me when I was young.
He'd say, you know, buddy, I gotta go take a little nap.
I'd complain. I'd sit outside the window
and wait for him to wake up.
Uh, he was the light of my life and I loved him so much.
And, uh, and there were other cousins there in town.
And, and so when I went to, um,
my wife met him just before he passed,
but um, when I was 14 years old, I went over
and he says, let's go to Piggly Wiggly.
Went to Piggly Wiggly.
And, but we stopped on the way home
and he bought two beers.
And we went back to the house
and we sat out under a China berry tree,
Drank us two beers.
And he looked over. He goes,
your daddy doesn't need to know about this.
He was so wonderful to me,
and I loved him so dearly when he passed,
I was there with all my cousins.
And the whole time I was there thinking, you know,
this has gotta be painful for them.
You know, 'cause I was his favorite.
And then they started sharing stories
and I found out I was just one of,
they all were, he loved all of 'em.
And he, I still think I was his favorite,
but I mean, they were all special to him.
And he took the time with every one of 'em.
I found out that today
or the last couple of days, being around Gary
and his friends and his family, how much he poured his life
into all his friends, and I mean, poured his life in it.
Now, unlike these three giants, I was grunt labor.
Um, I had a little old dinky company that I started,
and I'm just jumping in many years down the road.
And, uh, Gary was president at Orthofix
and Charlie was the CEOI had a, um,
basically a billing company.
And when I ran up, I billed a lot. I collected some of it.
And, uh, I had a giant debt in buying
products and inventory.
But, you know, I said, you know, you guys have got this, uh,
gigantic Titanic kind of boat.
You've only filled a half of the things.
And I said, you need my business
'cause you're a big billing operation.
And, uh, as I was sitting here selling my brains out, uh,
to Charlie and Gary at breakfast, Charlie sits back
and goes, well, I can write a check.
And that was it. And he goes, Gary, check it out.
And so Gary and I went
and did all the due diligence for doing all this.
And Gary bought my little company.
And, uh, and from then on
every company Gary went to, I'd get a phone call,
we got a job for you, Mikey, and, uh, it's more money.
You're gonna like it. You can do it.
And, and it was a wonderful relationship.
And every time I'd do it, I'd go, Hey, Gary,
I don't know anything about that.
I've never done relax. It's easy. You can do it.
We'll do it together. And it's, it, eh, you got it.
It, I was scared to death, you know, he hired me at, uh,
right medical, and I'd never sold a total
joint or an implant.
Or he says, I'm not hiring you to do that.
I want you to manage all these distributors.
And I had the whole south region, which was from
Arizona over to, you know, Florida and down.
And Gary made it easy.
He worked me like a mule.
Uh, keeping up
with Gary was the hardest thing I'd ever done in my life.
That was the hardest working that man I've ever met.
He would, and I thought I was a hardworking guy.
Gary would smoke you.
He absolutely would wear you out.
But after a while, drinking a lot of wine.
When I moved to Texas, I gotta tell you this, I I moved
two blocks away from him.
And I lived at their house. I had a room at their house.
I ate all his food. I drank all his wine, and it was great.
We went to play golf after work every day.
And, uh, he, he, we'd go out to Hurricane Creek
and, uh, we'd check in Gary, go to his locker
and had Gary Henley on it.
You know, I changed out in the car and we'd go play golf.
And Gary always, he paid and he'd pay.
And we went months of going to play golf.
And every Saturday, every day after work.
And he, and then one day he said to me, he says, uh,
I have bribed everybody on the membership team.
You're gonna get a membership.
I said, I'm tired of paying for you.
I said, man, I thought we had something going here.
So, uh, and I was an okay golfer. I wasn't a great golfer.
Gary was a great golfer.
Uh, I went
and played almost a,
I know 10 member guests out in Arizona with him.
He paid for my flights in and out.
He knew I didn't have any money.
I ate like a God while I was there.
Gary paid for all of it, drank some of the finest fluid.
And, um, Gary paid for all of it,
and he'd bring my wife.
It was, um, and
that was just the way it went our whole lives.
Gary just poured into my life and loved on me.
One of my favorite stories is when we got to Texas,
and really the greatest compliment Gary ever gave me,
and he doesn't know it was, uh, Mikey,
I know you're a religious guy.
He goes, um, you wanna go to church with us?
Um, I said, well, yeah. I said, where are your church?
He goes, it's out in Frisco. I said, who's the pastor?
He goes, I, it's kind of a famous guy.
I, I'm not sure. I was like, not sure.
So I said, sure. And he goes,
we'll go out to eat afterwards.
Of course he paid. And, uh, Gloria and I get into church.
Now, to back up a little bit, Gloria
and I, we've been married in three weeks, 53 years.
She's the love of my life.
But when I was a young hospital corpsman out in California,
we were driving down the road and we had some preaching on,
and there's a guy named Chuck Swindoll
who was preaching on the radio.
And I looked at her and I said,
I've never in my life heard the Bible taught like that.
I said, I've gotta start reading the Bible.
He, he brought the scripture to life,
and I mean, it was alive.
It was something that I'd never experienced.
So we walk into the church, we get the little
chuck swindle, and I'm like, can't be.
And then up comes his booming voice
and his chuck swindle,
Chuck Swindle.
Gloria and I were like,
Uh, you know,
we were going crazy. We looked at each other,
You know, Gary, I'm sure thought we were nuts.
And of course we went every Sunday after that.
And we told him all about, you know,
our relationship with Chuck.
And so we went to Chuck. I joined the choir.
It was, you know, we went over and over
and I would watch Gary listening to the greatest
Bible expository in I've ever heard in my life.
And, uh, I'd look over him sometimes
and there'd be a tear there.
So, um, but Gary's a man's man,
and, uh, he's real tough.
It, he's, he's about as cuddly as a rattlesnake.
I mean, grabbing a hold of him and loving him.
It was, it was hard.
You know, I'm, I come from a lovey-dovey family
and oh man, you know.
So, um, as we got along and we separated
and went our own ways doing things in the world,
and I retired
and, um, I talked to Gary.
We'd talk almost every day,
and he would say things that I thought were unique to me.
But then I found out all you guys,
he'd call me from prayer rock where he was walking up,
where he'd walk a million miles every day
and he'd walk up this mountain up to
what he called prayer rock.
And he'd tell me some of the things
that he was so grateful for.
And I'm so blessed,
and he uses all these Jesus words without using
the Jesus word.
But he was so in love with life,
and he was so appreciative of everything that he had.
And, um, and he called me sometimes just crying.
I don't know why. I don't know why.
And, uh, I go, I know why, you know?
But, uh, so I decided what I was gonna start doing
is when we'd talk, I'd end it with saying, Gary, I love you.
And he'd go, I'll see you, Mike.
Uh, it was like pulling hen's teeth, you know,
but I persevered.
And every time I'd hang up, I'd go,
all right buddy, I gotta go.
I love you, man. After a while it was love you too.
It was hard.
But after a while, years, I love you too, Mikey,
and I love you.
Care boy, love you too, buddy.
And it got easier and easier.
And when we'd get together, I could hug him
and he wouldn't pull away or do this, you know?
But, um, finding that soft spot for Gary
was easy in one respect, but tough in another.
Um,
ALS was horrible.
And like Erick said, it's, it's,
that's a disease from health.
Um, his mind stays sharp and has his body deteriorated.
Um, but I know, well,
you'll talk more about this,
but I mean, I know my brother's in heaven
and, uh, I guess I'm gonna finally
have to go to my notes.
You guys ruined it for me, but well, I won't do it now.
It is, it's in the Bible about a,
a story about a parable that Jesus tells about
Lazarus and the rich man.
And I won't tell you the whole story. You probably know it.
Well, I'll tell you most of it.
Lazarus sat outside the rich man's
place and he was a beggar, didn't have anything.
And the rich man had everything ate
anything you wanted, ate well dressed in
Luxurious robes and whatnot.
And, uh, Lazarus died.
And the story that reminds me so much of Gary here
is it said when he died, angels
came and grabbed him
and took him up to Abraham's bosom.
And I imagine angels carrying my
brother up to heaven.
'cause that's what happened when he died.
In Colossians first chapter,
about 21st, 22nd verse, somewhere in there,
it tells a story about how when you received Jesus Christ,
you're now, you're now a creature
of heaven on earth.
Eternity began right then.
And it says that one day
Christ is going to introduce me
in this case, Gary, to the Father,
and say, I want you to meet Mike Smith.
I want you to meet Gary Henley.
He is perfect, flawless,
without any blemish.
This is the Father. And you say, well, how is that?
It's because God doesn't see Gary anymore.
He doesn't see me. What he sees is Jesus Christ.
When you accept Christ, you take on Christ.
And, um, I disagree in that.
I don't think there's any fishing in heaven or hunting.
I think the Bible teaches that there's no marriage,
that, um, we know our spouse.
And, but it's a better relationship
than it is here on earth.
And rather than a corporation, um, brothers, sisters,
aunts, uncles, It's um, it's a marriage.
And Christ is at the center. It's like spokes.
And we're all married to Christ.
And it is, as it says in Revelations 22nd chapter,
it's the story of nose.
No more pain, no more sorrow.
Gary's got his voice back,
no crying, no agony, forever,
peace with Jesus Christ.
And I love that. And I loved my brother.
It's, um, he gave me
and my family so much
that it cannot be covered.
30 some
years that we were together.
But why I'm here, I don't know.
Gary had so many powerful, mighty friends
and why one of his dinging ball employees is up here
and why he loved me is a mystery, mystery to you guys too.
I know. Thank you so much.
I had only known last time would be the last time
I would've put off all the things I had to do.
I would've stayed a little, a little.
Now what I give for one more day with you,
Because There's a wound here in my heart where
something's missing
and they tell me that it's gonna heal with time.
But I know you are in a place
where all your wounds have been erased.
And knowing yours are healed, is healing
Mine.
The only scars in heaven,
they won't belong to me.
And you, There'll be no such
thing is broken
and all the will
and the thought that makes me smile
even
is that the only scars in
heaven on the hands.
I know the road you walked was anything but easy.
Drop your share of scar along
the way open.
Now you're standing in the sun, you fought your fight
and your races run.
The pain is all a million miles away.
The only
they won't belong to
Me. And
you,
There'll be no such thing is broken
and all the old.
And the thought that makes me smile now
down is that the only
scars in heaven on
the hands of hold now
Hall,
hall
Are on the hands of,
there's not a day goes by that I don't see you,
you live on and all the better parts of me
until I'm standing with you in the sun.
I'll fight this, fight in this race all
until I finally see what you can see.
Oh, you only scars in,
they won't belong to me.
And you.
There'll be no such thing is broken.
All the old would be made new.
And the God that makes me smile now
even fall
Down.
Is that the only scars in
heaven on the hands?
Hi everybody. I am Isabelle. I am one of IESs daughters.
And, um, all these stories are wonderful.
Of all the things that throughout the years, Pappy
and everybody has done.
Um, my story tonight is actually about last
weekend randomly.
Um, I told Grammy that I was gonna go to Bedlam
and go to Stillwater and get to go to the last one.
And she told me that she had some of Pappy's pullovers,
and if I wanted to have one, I could take them
and I could wear it to the game.
So of course I was like, I would love to bring Pappy
to Stillwater to bring 'em there with us on the last one.
So I put on that pullover, I went up
to Stillwater, I watched the game.
We got to tail, well, we got to tailgate,
um, and hang out there.
And Cole and I didn't have tickets.
So we were gonna go back to the refuge to watch the game,
um, hang out with family and spend time there.
And right when we're leaving,
Stillwater headed up to the refuge.
Cole gets a trail cam picture of a buck. And so we see this.
I look down, I'm in jeans, my pullover in boots,
and I was like, should we go sit in the sand right now
on this day on bed?
Bum, the game hasn't even started yet. Should we go?
So we raced all the way to the refuge, get in the stand.
I'm wearing my pappy's pullover feeling
all good and confident.
And, uh, we're watching the game,
the O Ssu game in the Stand in the Blind,
and, um, hoping that OSU pulls out something great.
And so as we're standing there, we're not even in there
for an hour and a butt comes out
and right then took the shot, made it, shot it.
I don't know what you say. And, um, my dad came with us
and came and went and got the deer.
We put it right in the back of the truck,
had been right back to the refuge
and caught the fourth quarter of the game
to see the wonderful thing happen.
The popes winning. And this entire time
I'm wearing something that meant so, so much to me.
Sorry. Um,
that entire day.
Oh, okay. That entire day we got to do three
wonderful things that meant so much to my pap.
We were in Stillwater at OSU, um, we got to go hunting
and most of all, um, we got to spend time
with family and I'll be there together.
And I know how much that means to him
and how much it means to me.
And now I know also if I ever need a little bit of luck
and a little bit of my pappy, I just need to put
that pullover on and I'm gonna be right by him.
Okay?
My name's Caroline Graham, um,
and I had the immense pleasure
of being an honorary granddaughter
To both Pappy and Grammy.
I wanna share a story about Poppy's
overwhelming generosity
that I think we've heard some stories of already,
but I wanna share a peace of mind.
Um, when I was 16 years old,
life circumstances happened
and I ended up moving into my aunt
and uncle's house, Katie and Eric.
And it just so happened that that same year, it was
spring of, um, it was springtime when I moved in with them
and there was a trip planned.
Henley's had planned this amazing trip to Hawaii
that coming summer, um, just a few months,
um, a head
and I had just moved in with them
and it was kind of a weird situation.
And I remember Grammy and Pappy came into town
and they handed me an envelope at the house
and I opened up this envelope
and it was a, a ticket to Hawaii.
And it meant so much to me.
Not only 'cause I got to go to Hawaii, which was awesome,
but because I had just gotten there
and I felt so overwhelmed
with the love and generosity that they took me in
and immediately treated me like one of their own.
And I can say from that day forward, I always felt that
By both Pappy and Grammy.
And I just wanted to share how much it meant to me
and just share the blessings that Pappy continued
to pour out into my life
and into everyone's life that he touched
and what a blessing he was
and a truly generous,
loving man and Pappy.
Alright everybody, um, I am
Ellison Henley now Marler and Pappy's oldest granddaughter.
And I want to share something with you all.
I really hope that it works.
Um, but about five years ago I received
a phone call from Pappy that unfortunately I missed,
but now fortunately I have saved on my phone forever.
Um, five years ago I was accepted into medical school,
which is a great accomplishment,
but I think that having his voice share with you
what an accomplishment was for him, um, is even greater.
So I hope it works and I hope you guys can hear it today.
Well, I got the news. Congratulations.
I'm so happy for you. Yeah.
Love you girl, making me cry.
I love you. Take care.
This is special for a lot of reasons.
As many of you know, he lost his
voice at the end of his life.
And so to be able to listen to him strong and happy
and joyful is so, so precious.
And that's the first thing that means
so much to me about this.
But the second thing is that what we've heard today from all
of you amazing men, is that Pappy was incredibly hardworking
and persistent in everything that he did in his work,
his family, and every part of his life.
We got to share a lot of that as we talked about medicine.
And I learned about his accomplishments
and finally understood what all of these weird words meant.
But his persistence
and his hard work is something that I aim to carry on
and his legacy and his honor, not just in work
but in family as well.
And the last thing that I feel like is
so important about this message is his pure joy.
You guys heard it? He says, yeah.
And that's just how he was.
He was be full of pure joy towards the end of his life.
He didn't have the words to express the joy,
but as much as you know, as much of, you know, you got
to sit with him and talk to him in person,
the joy came in the form of thumbs up.
So for me, I got the privilege
of spending a couple hours with him.
Um, two days prior to his passing with Grammy
and with Gabby as well.
The four of us sat in the sun room
and got to talk about life, all of its highs and lows.
And when we left I got to hold his hand
and Gabby got to hold his hand
and we all said we loved each other.
But what will be ingrained in my mind forever is looking
back in that room and him holding thumbs up.
And I just hope that you all can remember that as well,
that even in the hardest times in the ya accused times,
he still had that joy.
So I give that to you guys today too.
Thank you. Thank
You.
Good morning. Um, thank y'all for coming out.
I'm Paul Garrett. I'm uh, Gary's stepson.
Um, you know, him and my mom got married when I was five.
And from that moment on, he was just dad to me.
Um, you know, being Gary's redheaded stepchild,
I came to have, uh, became the master
of testing his patients that he was so well known for.
Um, and as I know y can attest
and a few others in the family,
when you tested his patients, you got a lecture that was
an all night event.
And I remember one of my very few seldom moments
of being an obstinate teenager, I asked,
can you just whip my ass and get this over with?
To which you said no
because then you wouldn't learn anything.
And that kind of summed up
who he was to so many of us.
He was our teacher and anything
that we needed to learn about.
Um, I remember shortly after him and my mom got married, um,
and we moved in together and I joined Cub Scouts.
And one of the first things we did was had the little derby
car competition and race.
And this is when he taught me how to sand a piece of wood.
You know, to me it felt like forever,
but it was probably five minutes
of just going back and forth.
And then he comes out and he gets his saw
and his Dremel tool and carves it all up
and made me the Batmobile, painted it all up,
got the Batman logo on there,
and it came with some little weights
that you could use to put in there.
And those were the only weights
that you were allowed to use.
Well, he made the front so sleek
that they weren't really gonna fit how he wanted them.
So he melted them down to fit into the little crevice
that he made to make sure that the car went as fast
as it possibly could.
So at the competition, of course, I won Best in Show
because it was the Batmobile.
And unfortunately we only ended up taking second
place in the races.
But I was more happy about Best in Show
'cause I was in the Batman.
He created the vehicle from
my current favorite movie.
And you know, as, as I look back, you know, one
of our very first and earliest bonding experiences,
you know, and something that he just took the time with
to do with me, you know,
the make me the special feelings.
Um, and about 10 years later, he's teaching me
how to drive a real car.
And I remember we went out to, uh,
there was a big church just north
of Plano when we lived down there
that had a huge parking lot.
So we went on a Saturday when it was empty
and he just made it so simple.
He's like, all right, pay attention to everything in front
of you because that's most likely
where something's gonna happen.
You have these mirrors to check,
always know what's going on around you.
You want to smoothly push on the brake
and gas so you're not jerking and jumping and let's go.
And we went out and he taught me how to drive with some
of the most simple and basic instructions.
And I just remember he just taught things so well
and he would simplify them
and was just there to share in
your learning and your success and your growing.
And it was just something he was always there for.
Um, you know, reading on the back
of the little handout we got today, you know,
there towards the bottom it says Pappy was an unwavering
cheerleader for those he loved.
And he believed in us more than we believed in ourselves
most of the time, which is entirely true.
You know, there's so many times when, you know,
I thought I was in over my head on something I got myself in
and he would just be like, well, hey, let's figure it out.
You're smart, you'll get it.
And just, you know, to be there
and to care so deeply for so many of us,
no matter what through thick
and thin, you know, I can't tell you
how many times he picked me up when I fell, you know,
I'm just thinking, oh, he's gonna be so mad at me.
He's like, okay, it's done. How do we fix it?
How do we move forward? And that was it.
There was never dwelling on negatives.
There was never
beating a dead horse.
There was just learning and growing and being supportive
and just taking people in
everyone, you know?
I mean, One of his favorite things to do was
host parties and dinners and cook for everyone.
I remember shortly
after I got outta high school, you know, he is like, well,
I'm making a pot of chili.
Why don't you invite some friends over?
And then it becomes a thing of, well, hey, let's cook.
Let's invite some people over.
It wasn't always just his friends, he wanted
to host your friends, the people that were special to you
and just be communal.
He is. And he always said,
you can always learn something from everybody.
And he truly embodied that and exemplified it.
And I'll forever be grateful you know that he's the man
who raised me and taught me to be the man that I am today.
So thank y'all for coming and sharing in his life with us.
It's nice to see that he meant so much to so many others.
Gentlemen, you did a good job.
And Lynette of course, and I held it together.
But ladies, please don't make me follow you ever again.
Ever. Most of you know me pretty well.
I cry like a baby at my own weddings.
The odds of getting through this are slim. But we'll try.
In 1978, I was eight years old, we told some
of these stories earlier and my dad invited me
to go on a hunting trip to the panhandle, Oklahoma Beaver,
specifically, we do have a town in Oklahoma named Beaver.
And I have to tell you, as a young man, actually a kid
to be invited on a trip to go hunting with the men
was a great honor, cliff.
You were there. He took me out into a big
sunflower field, giant meadow on a beautiful giant ranch
and set me next to a stock tank
that had a windmill next to it.
Gave me a single shot. Four 10, yes.
At eight years old, I shot a shotgun all the time.
And he said, you stay here and shoot Dove.
And I'll be like, right down the road a little bit,
cross the road, right, right by you.
I'll be right here. And I sat down next to that windmill
and that stock tank and I started shooting at Dove.
And I wasn't a very good shot then either.
And I missed a lot.
And every time I missed, I blamed it on the shotgun
that I just couldn't reach out far enough to hit a dove.
So I'd take a few steps away from the stock tank
and the windmill and I'd venture a little further out into
the sunflower patch.
And I kept shooting and I kept walking and I kept wandering
and eventually the bird stopped flying.
The dove had gone to roost or something.
And in the absence of the dove, I looked around
and I discovered that I was
standing in a head high sunflower patch lost
as I could possibly be,
To which I started yelling my dad's name, dad
screaming actually at one point, even at one point,
taking shotgun shells and putting them in the four 10
and shooting them in some fashion
that I thought might signal an SOS rather than me continuing
to just shoot for no reason.
And when I gave up on yelling and screaming
and shooting, I started crying
and I put my hands over my face and I bawled
and eventually fell to my knees
and sat there in that sea of sunflowers
and anticipated death.
At any moment, I'm sure it had been days I was out
there, or at least minutes.
And about the time that I felt like I would succumb
to the elements, I felt a hand on my shoulder.
And I looked up and there was my dad staring at me
and I instantly jumped up with joy and gave him a big hug
'cause he had saved my life.
But instantly as well, my joy turned to anger
and I looked him in the eye and I was mad at him.
I was mad at him because I had yelled
and screamed trying to find him.
And he had abandoned me.
He had left me in the wilderness to die.
And so I told him such.
And after I threw my fit
and berated him like an eight year old can do with
that same smile that you see
and the calmness that's been mentioned.
He just sat there and I went on for a little bit.
And when I finally got silent
and I shut my mouth, he said,
son, I never left you.
I've been right here the entire time you were screaming
and yelling and shooting a gun
and chasing dove and walking away.
I never left you. He actually said
to me specifically,
I will always be here for you.
I promise you that. What
reassuring words could an eight year old ever hope
to hear from his father?
I'll never, ever in my life forget it.
I told you this story today 'cause I have a million.
And that was the only one that I wanted to share.
In fact, that story would become symbolic
of times to come in my life
and in fact in his life.
See, obviously not all of you knew him as a father,
but most of you in the room could identify him
as someone in your life.
I'm so thankful for the testimonies we've heard today,
the sharing of some of those incredible identities
that Gary had a great
businessman, an entrepreneur.
I mean, men and women and friends
and family have stood up here
and shared how Gary impacted their lives.
And I've heard nothing but amazing stories
for the last week and a half.
And again, we could fill this auditorium with the rest
of our days telling them,
but he was so many things to so many people.
Again, leader, mentor, father, husband,
uncle, brother Pappy.
He was a great golfer. We heard that he loved to fish.
He was a great Turkey hunter, the best of all of us.
He was a crazy noodler.
If you don't know what that was, he stuck his hands in holes
and pulled out catfish for no apparent reason.
He was our boat captain. You were his first mate.
He was a minor league baseball player.
If you didn't know that. He was drafted by the St.
Louis Cardinals in Gary Fashion.
They wanted him to play catcher.
And he said, no, I wanna play second base so I'm not coming.